hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well a significant portion of the third
part of immanu K proma to any future
metaphysics is taken up by the
analysis of what Kant is going to call
the dialectic of pure reason or the
dialectical usage of pure reason which
for K is not a good thing dialectical
going astray it's not as good as
something that's actually secure and
it's going to lead us into all sorts of
errors and so this is part of the
critique of pure reason that is carried
out in the the work named as such and
also here in the proma in a much shorter
form so Kant is going to begin by
drawing an analogy between the concepts
of the uh understanding which we call
categories you know and uh the ideas of
pure reason also Concepts you know for
this faculty of of reason and he is
going to tell us in section uh
43 that in the critique of pure reason I
took care to Endeavor not only to
carefully distinguish several kinds of
cognition but to derive Concepts
belonging to each of them from their
common source I did that so that I could
by knowing where they originated I could
determine their use with safety and have
this invaluable but never previously
anticipated advantage of knowing the
completeness of my enumeration
classification and specification of
Concepts aiori right without this
metaphysics is mere raps city rapity is
not a good term for anymore than
dialectic is so what's he going to do he
is going to look for
Clues uh just as he did with the
concepts or categories of the uh
understanding he's going to look for
clues in Logic for the ideas of reason
so he says I found the origin of the
categories in the four logical functions
of all judgments of the understanding so
it was quite quite natural for me to
seek the origin of the ideas in the
three functions
function of syllogisms now he's we're
seeing the term syllogism being used in
here and we rightly associate that with
logic and
argumentation Kant isn't actually using
sismos in German he's using a different
term
funus SCH means a conclusion but it can
also mean a process of uh inquiry and
inference and it can mean syllogism
because that's a particular kind of of
inference that's carried out going from
premises to a
conclusion and for n of reason right so
these are the the inferences of Reason
syllogism works just fine especially
since Kant himself is going to be
looking at
logic a topic that many are quite
familiar with among his
readership and which he taught to
students himself throughout the course
of his long career so the syllogisms are
going to give us clues about how we can
classify things he says as soon as these
pure concepts of reason that is the
transcendental ideas are given they
could hardly unless they be held innate
that's an idea that uh rationalists had
about where our ideas come from they
could hardly be found anywhere else than
in the same
activity of Reason which so far as it
regards mere form constitutes The
Logical element of
syllogisms The Logical element of
syllogisms is formal it is not about the
particular
content it's about the structure of how
things are actually set up within the
syllogisms and then he says uh in so far
as it represents judgments of the
understanding as determined with respect
to one or another form o priori these
constitute transcendental concepts of
pure reason so we got on the one hand
syllogisms you know whatever they happen
to be and on the other hand we've got
transcendental ideas of pure reason and
there is a
correspondence between them which we can
effectively chart out a sort of mapping
or uh division uh on each side following
each other so he tells us that the
formal difference of syllogisms makes
their division their
unid into three kinds categorical
hypothetical and
disjunctive so categorical syllogisms
essentially tell us what what something
is is you know a example of that you
know all men are mortal Socrates is man
therefore Socrates is Mortal right I
think that's pretty easy to wrap your
head around hypothetical syllogism is
going to involve a hypothesis an if then
statement right so uh if um Socrates is
uh a man then he is Mortal Socrates is a
man therefore he is Mortal right and you
know we could formalize this is as a
modus ponin if P then Q uh P therefore Q
we can also have invalid uh hypothetical
syllogisms as well well and and same
thing with categorical syllogism so
affirming the consequent right if P then
q q therefore P
right it's certainly a hypothetical
syllogism but not a valid one kant's not
worried about validity at this point
then we have disjunctive syllogisms and
K actually has a very interesting
footnote about this so he says in
disjunctive judgments we consider all
possibility as divided
in respect to a particular concept we're
saying something is this or it's this
it's not this so it's this right so he
says uh by the ontological principle of
the thoroughgoing determination of a
thing in general I understand the
principle that either the one or the
other of all possible contradictory
predicates must be assigned to any
object this is at the same time the
principle of all disjunctive judgments
constituting the foundation of the
totality of all possibility and it's the
possibility if every object in general
is considered as determined this may
serve as a brief explanation of the
above proposition that the here's the
the payoff the activity of Reason in
disjunctive syllogisms is
formally the same as that by which it
fashion the idea of a totality of all
reality containing in itself
the positive member of all contradictory
predicates so you know when we're
thinking about just a plain old
disjunctive
syllogism Socrates is Mortal or he is
Immortal right those are contradictory
predicates Socrates is not Immortal
therefore Socrates is Mortal that's not
about the entirety of of the you know
being as uh such but we could extend it
formally into that concept and so here's
where he's going to get his his mileage
so to speak out of this so we've got
these three
functions of syllogisms three kinds of
syllogisms and he's going to tell us the
concepts of reason that are founded on
these contain therefore three things
first notice Begin by saying the
idea of the complete figan this is a
term that's going to be used in each of
these subject subject and he doesn't say
substance but rather the
substantial right so we have an idea of
a subject of a complete subject of a
substance metaphysicians have been using
this for uh Millennia right by the time
that that K is talking about this so
that's going to be one kind of idea or
ideas we're going to come to in a
moment secondly the idea of the complete
once again fullan brought to its
fruition extended as far as possible
series of
conditions right of conditioning you
could say of one thing conditioning
another and just as this has to do with
substance this has to do with causality
it right because what does a cause do
well it produces the effect it brings it
into existence but it also conditions it
it specifies it it makes it be what it
is that's why we call it a cause of that
effect so that that corresponds to the
hypothetical now why does that
correspond to the
hypothetical uh
because you know you can set up if the
cause doesn't exist the effect doesn't
exist if the cause does exist the effect
does exist there's a hypothetical
connection between them then we get the
disjunctive now here's where it starts
to get a little weird right so he says
the determination the btim a term that
uh was translated earlier as destination
and we could say Harmony as well or uh
Resonance of all
Concepts in the idea
of a complete once again
figan
complex uh in of what is possible
everything that is possible so a
determination of all Concepts all
possible Concepts in the idea of a
complete complex uh of what is possible
this corresponds to you know we've got
substance
causality Community Kant talks about
that uh quite a bit as well so he goes
on and then he's going to say there's
another correspondence involved here we
can call the first the psychological
idea here but he's going to actually put
that in the plural in the section this
is where it gets a little bit dicey
because when you read that section as
we're going to look at elsewhere it kind
of appears
as if there's only one psychological
idea but he does
sayia right so you know should that be
plural or not that's that's a little bit
debatable then under the hypothetical
the idea of the complete series of
conditions dealing with cause and effect
the
cosmological ideas and the cosmological
ideas do seem to be plural don't they
then we have something that can't
possibly be plural because is uniting
everything into one thing not one thing
but one idea the theological idea and
he's going to tell us a little bit about
each of these in uh section 44 right he
says whether the soul is or is not a
simple substance that's something that
we're going to look at under the
psychological idea makes sense Su is
soul right um and then it goes on
likewise the cosmological ideas of the
beginning of the world or its eternity
right he's also going to talk about
causality you know whether we are free
or not in that and then he says finally
uh we have uh the uh design of nature is
being drawn from the will of a Supreme
Being that would be part of the
theological idea right there wouldn't it
so each of these is connected to a
particular uh kind of syllogism each of
these is an idea and here's the the
ultimate payoff of making all these
distinctions each of these is a way in
which reason when it's not controlling
itself critically leads us astray and
gives us bad metaphysics as a product of
that it generates Illusions errors that
we can get drawn into to and Kant is
going to call this the
dialectic of pure reason which much of
this this part of the proma as I
mentioned earlier is indeed about so
he's going to say each of these give
occasion to dialectic each in its own
way and we have a division of the whole
dialectic of pure reason
into
paralogism uh parag paralogism
right in in German antomy anom in in
German and then ideal or ideal it's just
a cognet there all these are cognets
actually so we have three different
determinant modes of going astray and
really the antinomy is going to be
itself plural we have four of them
discussed in that that particular
section which takes up a significant
portion of this part
and so he's going to say through this
derivation now here's where he's going
to conclude and this is quite important
we may feel assured that all of the
claims of pure reason are
completely represented for right we are
using
representations of these and that none
can be wanting or missing why because
the faculty of Reason itself the
capacity of reason the fugan really
ferun feran is how it's it's talked
about in the German from which they all
take their origin from which they all
Spring right is thereby completely
surveyed anen right so literally
measured out we have
exhaustively studied all the
possibilities for how reason gets itself
into these
dialectical difficulties by by taking as
our leading cue or our path the
distinction of these three different
kinds of syllogisms and so Kant you know
he's showing you that what he's doing
here is directly analogous to what he
did with the understanding and the
categories and logical judgments he's
doing that here with the uh syllogisms
or the uh processes of inference of
Reason itself to show us where we aim at
completeness this you know fendig again
we aim at
totality at covering everything in a way
that cannot be realized within the scope
of experience and the understanding
reason itself must be what engages in
the study the critical analysis of
Reason
itself